[Music]
tuesday edition pro football talk live
free agency coming in 15 days the tag
window closes in 12 days and for now
teams can apply a franchise tag and a
transition tag under the rules of the
current cba if the new cba is ratified
look at some of those one tag sorry you
get one tag and only one tag that's fine
chris is looking at the list of the
pft's free agent top 100 that is showing
on the screen for those of you listening
on radio so for some of the big names
should they get tagged will they get
tagged there are plenty of reports out
there and most of the reports are
consistent most of them are obvious i
just saw a little blurb that dak
prescott's likely to be tagged do you
think yeah you think he's likely you
think
all right
hand out the pulitzer's folks dak
prescott is likely to be tagged so um
let's start with him i mean you know the
only question there is what level of the
tag and there's a report from nfl media
over the weekend it would be the
exclusive tag we talked about this
yesterday right that potentially sets
the stage for a year to year thing
because it pays dak prescott more money
2020 and 2021 but the real question for
the cowboys is there a way they can work
out a deal with dak before that deadline
so then they can tag amari cooper chris
that's really the question that is the
question that's what they need to get
done i mean yes of course i'm all for
tagging deck prescott like you said
that's the captain obvious answer of the
year right there uh you know again this
is dak prescott yeah maybe not one of
the five best quarterbacks in football
but he's one of the 10 best right now
and that's saying something and he's
capable of carrying that team in moments
where they need him too so yes you tag
him uh hopefully like you said uh if
that they can get that done and then
move on to amari cooper because they
don't want to let him walk out the door
for free of course what they traded for
him to get him from the raiders
dynamic we discussed yesterday as well
the influx of great young rookie
receivers could make the cowboys think
hey we could let emory cooper go to the
market maybe the market's not going to
be there for amari cooper because teams
are thinking we can get guys a lot
cheaper and younger in the draft mike
let me ask you this when when does the
team know or not know that the cba is
gonna happen or not happen and then they
could use the franchise tag and the
transition tag in this rare year like
some people were reporting yeah some
people were reporting that the vote on
the new cba was going to happen
yesterday i was told all along no
because they don't have the cba ready
yet right you've got the lawyers
scrambling to draft this multiple
hundred page document that then will
have to be event and it's funny they
sent out an email to all players on
friday saying they have an opportunity
to review the full cba before they vote
on it yeah do you real it's like reading
the phone book are you going to read the
phone book before you vote no just tell
me the highlights and i'll make a
decision but they want to get that done
at some point in the next 12 days
because in 12 days the window closes on
the franchise tag slash transition tag
decision so i think it's going to move
quickly and once it happens we'll know
one way or the other if the vote is yes
then uh you get one tag if the vote is
no which is bad news for the league it's
good news for a team like the cowboys
they could use the franchise tag on dak
prescott transition tag on amari cooper
another team that's got that same
conundrum tennessee titans ryan
tannehill quarterback derek henry
running back now represented both by the
same agency which is going to refuse i
believe to do a long-term deal for
either guy they're going to force the
titans to use one or both tags which of
those two guys would you be more likely
to franchise the back of the running
back yeah this is an interesting
conversation and you know i didn't
realize tandon hill had left his agent
you know i i i forgot about that last
week and you know now they're both with
caa right am i right about that which
yes you know that that's again yeah you
know when agents caa a place like that
they they got a lot they got to hand
their hands on a lot of inventory and
that means they can corner the market
and corner and and frame conversations
and contracts that's what goes on in the
nfl that's a little dangerous here if
you're going to make me pick between one
of the two i'm going to franchise derek
henry i mean derek henry is arguably the
best at his position in the sport right
now uh i think a running back contract
is easier to figure out than the
quarterback contract too and then this
would be the other reason i would go
derek henry because i feel like a guy
like ryan tannenhill
they're gonna be he's gonna be reluctant
he's he's carved out a niche for himself
in tennessee right he worked so hard
this year to become a god become the guy
there the franchise quarterback become a
leader in the locker room it's not easy
just to go somewhere else and do that
again and have everything fall in place
to where you have the success you just
had there so i think you can err on
let's franchise derek henry and let's
err on the fact that we think ryan
tannehill will want to be back here
because he's established something with
us and we kind of have the leg up on
everybody else and free agency as far as
tannehill is concerned
what would you pay tan hill on a
long-term deal how much per year well i
you know i would look at something you
know again
short-term contract at first i'm not
gonna go out and just give them like a
six-year deal or anything like that i i
would be like they're all short-term
well yes you're right but i would be
guaranteed for two to three years right
it would be a two-year deal exactly
something like that maybe to where you
can get out after the first year how
much
i'm gonna say somewhere between
you know for right now the market 27 and
30 million is somewhere in that range i
think so yes you know somewhere around
there 25 to 30 somewhere right around
there you know maybe you finagle it with
the the signing bonus and guaranteed
money to where that first year hits for
more than you know 30 million dollars or
whatever but then the second year
significantly lower and it averages out
to a to a manageable number i don't know
what what say you florio
well look i i
i asked you the question because the
franchise tag non-exclusive is going to
be in the range of 27 million yeah
you're gonna tag him that's what you're
looking at if you were gonna say 22 to
25 then you definitely don't tag the guy
i don't know what the market's going to
be for him because i don't know what
other teams think look yeah there is a
concern based upon past history that
ryan tannehill is going to get injured
right or he's going to revert to the
performance we've seen in the past he's
always been
kind of a guy that will give you those
flashes those moments but never deliver
over the long term he delivered last
year got the team to the brink of the
super bowl i think there would be a much
different vibe about ryan tannehill if
they'd gotten to the super bowl and they
had that 10 point lead in the second
quarter over the kansas city chiefs at
arrowhead stadium but i don't know who
else is out there i mean
look i'm not hearing a whole lot of buzz
of people lining up to sign jameis
winston nope and i'm not hearing a lot
of buzz of people lining up to sign ryan
tannehill right it's all philip rivers
and tom brady with the dash of teddy
bridgewater it's not like there's going
to be a land rush for ryan tannehill if
he's available it could be like the
bucks though where teams are thinking
they're not letting this guy get away so
they're really not putting him on the
middle of the radar screen for a guy
they could go get but that it's not like
we came out of indy with oh there are
four other teams that are ready to make
ryan tannehill a major offer on the
first day of free agency no they're not
but i think i would think he'd be one
that teams were laying laying in the
weeds for a little bit i i do you know
yes you know we hear the the marquee
names brady and rivers and things like
that but like you know if somehow he
became a free agent and the cults who
were you know in a situation where hey
they're they're looking for a guy to be
the quarterback you know maybe for the
future or at least for the next year or
two you know they might be a team that
gets involved in this conversation but
you know back to the original point you
would franchise derek henry here right
is that what you're saying yes yes yes
right yeah because look here's the thing
and and this is the unfortunate aspect
of running backs cashing in todd gurley
cashes in great for todd gurley bad for
the rams and bad for anybody else who
wants to cash in ezekiel elliott cashes
in great for zeke bad for the cowboys
based on how he performed last year and
you know you look at derek henry and you
say well you're going to break the bank
and give the guy 15 16 17 million a year
great for him
but is he still going to be you know do
you make that leap of faith that he's
going to continue this trajectory and
the difference between him and the
others the others you could argue you
know their best years came early in
their career
derrick henry's been on a slow
progression where he gets better and
better and better
uh
and and here's the problem they didn't
wear him out the first two years that
you know if you tag him right this year
chris and he has 2 000 yards then what
do you do next year yeah right right
right you're almost better off just
biting the bullet and doing the
long-term deal with derek henry if you
truly believe he's going to continue to
play at that level the one thing about
derek henry and i well i told him to his
face he's a modern-day jim brown yeah
but it takes him three or four steps to
get up to jim brown level right those
first few steps he's not barry sanders
he's not that burst through the line and
if he if you knock him down before he
burst through the line that's how you
shut him down yeah no no doubt about it
those bigger running backs he's so long
you're right it's more of a buildup
speed than we see out of some of the
marquee running backs uh but you know
didn't get a lot of wear and tear on his
body the first two years of his career
and you know doesn't to me does not look
like he's lost a step you know you you
bro mentioned ezekiel elliott ezekiel
concerns me that concerns me if i'm
dallas right now i'm really like i'm a
little worried about the ezekiel
elliott's you know contract and
situation listen i know i was a guy that
banged on the table for him to get his
money i do not like the way he looked
last year i would seriously be sitting
there thinking about i'm not so sure if
we can't get out of this contract right
now i might not get out i really i'm
dead serious about that derek henry i
don't feel that way first off i think
he's different off the field i think he
takes care of himself a little bit
better i don't think he parties the way
ezekiel elliott does and yes i just
don't see any signs of slowing down the
one thing about derek henry that
impresses me mike and you know think
about it you don't see a lot of huge car
crash type hits you know it's it's not
that way he's not like he delivers them
he delivers them he does and he has a
nice way of kind of again like we've
talked about like with christian
mccaffrey of he doesn't let people
square them up a whole lot and just have
those boom and just stop dead in your
track type collisions and i think that
goes a long way to him lasting a number
of more years because of his size and
the way he runs
from derrick henry to hunter henry
there's a report the chargers will be
applying the tag to their tight end wow
they can't get a long-term deal done
this guy's had some injuries yeah right
when he plays he plays well uh what do
you think about the idea of giving him
that kind of a one-year deal to keep him
off the open market yeah i mean i to me
that's dicey this is the one i look at
and go wow i mean really we're gonna
franchise you know hunter henry here a
guy that's you know never had more than
700 yards receiving in his career and
we're gonna you know give him a huge
chunk of money now it's a very important
position for this team and anthony lynn
you know they want to use the tight end
they want to run the football do that um
but i guess i would you know that would
be one where yeah i don't think i would
tag him i don't i don't think i would
tag him i would try to get a long-term
deal out throw some good money at him
here you know for a year or two but the
injury concern lack of production all
would would bother me right now
yeah i agree with you there and uh uh
we'll we'll see how that one plays out
shaq barrett buccaneers
right yeah 19 and a half sacks i believe
last year led the league the pft
defensive player of the year for what
that's worth and not much other than
satisfaction i think you got to keep
them around bruce arian's touting to us
last week the team's defense the defense
doesn't get better if the best piece of
it last year walks away yeah exactly
right it's something to build on this
guy's special he really is and people
might go oh is it a one-year thing hey
listen he was really good in denver he
just got stuck behind some names and
because he was a lower draft pick
sometimes that's the politics of
football but you know he showed his butt
last year he was awesome and yes you
franchise tag him you don't even think
about it and you hopefully you can go a
long-term deal he showed his butt yeah
that's not showing your butt is not a
good thing well i don't know where i
don't i don't know where that came from
jersey he showed his butt
well they usually say you know show his
ass okay sorry i'm saying that word they
do and in the future who's they i don't
know in the football world that means
like it's a good thing it's they as in
dumb football people that's right and
i'm including myself in that
one more eric armstead the 49ers pass
rusher had a career high in sacks last
year thanks to i think nick bosa and d
schwart in large part do you do you just
assume if you're the 49ers that we'll
find somebody else to provide that
presence and take advantage of the
attention paid to the outside pass rush
and we don't need to make the investment
in armstead either long term or short
term well that that you know it's it's
dicey first off as we both know that is
a huge reason of why they got to the
super bowl was because it was the best
d-line in football
i would probably tag eric armstead now
the 49ers the interesting thing there is
what plays into this decision as well is
what are they going to do with deforest
buckner you know where where is that
going to go is he going to ask for a
long-term deal because he had a
phenomenal year you do so they're going
to have to figure out how they want to
balance that they're not going to be
able to pay all these guys big money
they're going to lose somebody whether
it's armstead deforest buckner whatever
it may be
and they might just you know i would
expect them to tag eric armstead right
now they're in the super bowl window i
would do it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports